personally a one sign another extend and
pretend I'm allergic to extending and
pretending it was a yes but come Monday
night you will not be finance master I
will not it won't be as perfect I am
quite confident Larry great people have
had enough of extending and pretending
like the rest of the world by the way
you personally works on a deal without
that reorganization has been perfect
that is no I prefer fundamental I prefer
I prefer to cut my arm off but it lines
by necessity are inflexible but our red
lines and they're a red line so such so
there is common ground I wish that we
had the drachma make no mistake this is
not the statement that I wanted that I
wish we had I wish we had never entered
this monetary union and I think that
deep down old member states of the
eurozone I would agree with us now
because it was very badly constructed
but once you're in you don't get up
without a catastrophe we have the right
to be heard and we have the right to
challenge the logic of the program that
has clearly failed this crisis that
began in two thousand eight nine ten
instead of helping us come closer
together it is creating centrifugal
forces that is making the political
process of unifying even harder and that
is something that should we should lose
sleep over as Germans as Greeks as
Portuguese as fins as Slovaks as French
we will compromise we will compromise
and we will compromise in order to come
to a speedy agreement but we're not
going to end up being compromised
I'm not going to give you first
conference while I'm trying to school